foreign
kicks us off in my hometown the great
city of Boston Massachusetts Kyle
welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call how you
doing
good um so I have less of a numbers
question more of a philosophical
question
um so just for some background
um I'm 24 years old I've been working
for the federal government since I was
18.
um so on paper my job is amazing you
know great retirement great benefits I
made great money for my age
but ever since covet happened we're
fully remote now
um and you know in terms of my mental
health I think things have deteriorated
a little bit and I guess ultimately
before I keep on blabbering my question
is is it bad that the only fulfillment
my job is giving me is a paycheck yeah
it is that's why I wrote my last book
from paycheck to purpose because if we
look at work and experience work as just
a thing that we do for provision
slowly our soul seeps out of our body
I don't apologize for saying this I
believe that we were created to
contribute through our work I was just
reading something today on the plane
back from Minneapolis
that a professor out of the University
of California
did 20 years of research studying people
um and they found that the good stress
meaning the stress from a challenge
a challenge is something that we we it
pushes us we're able to do it but it
pushes us
and it rewards us when we meet that
challenge and work that the longer we do
that the longer we live that we're
healthier so there I mean this is the
way that the the human body and the Soul
we are spirits
uh this is the way we're wired and so
absolutely and it's already happening to
you you're 24 years of age
and and your soul is slowly seeping out
of your body and if you just think about
the average American Kyle spends and
you're on the front end of this 90 000
Plus hours at work in their lifetime
Monday through Friday and you go in and
you have no fulfillment what's going to
happen is
and and it's more intense for for for
some people than others
but the undercurrent begins to go wait a
second my work doesn't matter to me
and then we start to say do I matter
and now that can get really intense
you're starting to feel that yeah
yeah and just you know it's just hard
because
um you know I have a great boss but um
the work just isn't challenging but then
I think you know
um I'm already making eighty thousand
dollars and I basically have a ladder
that'll take me up to 150 000 so then I
think
um you know well even if my job isn't
giving me fulfillment maybe I can devote
every other hour of the day to doing
things that fulfill my time but like you
said I mean that 90 000 hour number is
pretty staggering you know yeah well so
you make a very good point and I'm glad
you brought this up so you could choose
that path
to say I'm going to stay in this path
and I'm going to eventually get up the
ladder and make 150 000 have all this
government you know uh retirement
accounts and all these things and then
I'm going to find fulfillment you know
in volunteering at nights and weekends
you could choose that and I'm not going
to say that that is wrong I don't think
this is a right or wrong but I would
challenge you that that is a less than
choice you could leave the government
sector and go to the private sector and
make as much and completely more
and actually do something that fulfills
you
you know we we've got the I think part
of it part of it's definitely
complacency too you know no I've just
been just wondering no I'm gonna tell
you complacency is the output I'm gonna
tell you what's going on and this is not
judging you I'm just trying to help you
it's not complacency it's Comfort you've
gotten comfortable with what you know
and even though you're even though
you're miserable you're going well at
least I know what to expect and we
humans would rather be miserable than
uncomfortable
but Life Starts at the end of our
comfort zone somebody said I saw it on a
t-shirt or a coffee mug one time I'm
sorry I don't know who to attribute that
to it's not mine but it's true
and so I would tell you Kyle I'm going
to give you my get clear assessment
which is going to measure your talent
what you do best your passion work you
love and then your mission results that
motivate you when you all three of those
things come together it looks like this
you're using what you do best to do what
you love to produce results that matter
to you let me tell you what's happening
you're on fire you can't burn out that
flame cannot be extinguished because you
are doing what your creator puts you on
this planet to do and I'm going to give
you that get clear assessment because my
challenge to you is not just to take the
assessment but to look at that purpose
statement and the detailed report you're
going to get on all three of those areas
and let that become a high level job
description and then because you've got
good experience and you've got skill
let's make the transition we don't have
to rush you're in no dire situation you
love your boss all that's good but now
is the time at 24 to choose the path
of purpose and it is going to be
uncomfortable but I can tell you this
Kyle when you get to the end of your
journey and I hope you make it to a long
uh life and an old age I'd rather you
look back and reminisce
not regret and that's the choice we as
humans have to choose and Ken there
seems to be a four buckets or so where
someone either they don't get paid
enough but they love what they do they
get paid really well like Kyle but they
hate what they do then there's the I I
don't get paid enough and I hate what I
do right and then there's the Sweet Spot
which is what you're talking about you
can get paid really well and love what
you do yeah or here's another thing you
can love what you do and it's enough
money
the third largest group of net worth
millionaires are teachers with a median
salary a median of sixty thousand
dollars you know I'm all for people
making as much money as you want but I
can tell you this uh
meaning is what I define success by not
money well there's been so many studies
that show after a certain dollar amount
you don't actually increase happiness
and joy the income number seventy five
thousand dollars is pretty interesting
so people think well if I just made 80
Ken my life would no you go with you and
so an increased income lifestyle creep
happens you just spend more and you go
well that wasn't it either I don't have
the joy in my life I don't have the
passion that's exactly right I mean
here's the deal when it's all said and
done and we want you to have Financial
Peace and that's what we're about here
on the Ramsey show but when it's all
said and done all of that financial
piece is going to allow you to make the
contribution you want to make anyway and
so let's be let's begin to look at work
as more than just provision let's look
at as an opportunity for contribution
I know it reminds me of this quote I
think it was from Rachel Cruz she said
contentment turns what we have into
enough yeah great man there is such a
lack of contentment in today's culture
because of all the marketing and
everything's 24 7 and all the inputs we
have uh it says you're not enough you
don't have enough you need to be doing
more you need to be more and man that is
an endless Chase
so we gotta stop and go enough is enough
we're gonna learn to be content and if
we're not content with where we are
we're going to be driven to get to that
next thing but man if you keep chasing
you'll never get there yeah it's true so
run your own race if you want to change
careers you have the ability to do that
in this country there's so much
opportunity out there but please don't
stay Paralyzed by indecision don't do
that that is the worst place to be take
action in your life you have control